[Music]
hello everyone I'm waiting sierpinski
I'm head of engineering at Forbes I'm
responsible for our development our QA
our DevOps and data products and I've
been with the company for 11 years
hi my name is William director of
engineering at Forbes I lead the team of
application engineers under Vadim and
today we're gonna take you on a journey
of our cloud migration our all to the
cloud we'll talk about our mistakes what
we learned our challenges and benefits
so hope you enjoy the journey
yeah so let's start by talking a little
bit about why we moved to the cloud so
there are three key areas that drove us
to move from previously being on Prem
with the data center into a cloud-based
solution particularly in this case with
GCP velocity abstraction and stability
for velocity we of course wanted to
increase our speed to market delivering
more features to users so they could
read Forbes calm in the most efficient
way and being able to target more
efficiently ci CD a major part of course
of velocity making sure that we could
automate our entire flow as we go along
and then those both tie into having a
very fluid soft software development
lifecycle abstraction was also massive
for us in choosing which cloud to move
with GCP and a lot of the managed
services made it very easy for engineers
without ops backgrounds or traditional
server-side backgrounds to jump right
into building applications and getting
that to work and also removed our
infrastructure concerns of course coming
from a data center and having physical
servers that was a whole other level to
worry about as well and then stability
of course being able to leverage managed
kubernetes and is's and more led to
scalability availability and disaster
recovery leti recoverability recover
ility yeah yeah speed on automation is a
forefront for us everywhere and
obviously in technology too yeah so
let's talk a little bit about the lift
what we actually had to move going from
our previous infrastructure onto our new
Google cloud-based solution
so forbes.com it is a website but the
site when you visit it is actually a bit
over 50 different services for the
architecture that we have in place and
those span across the front ends that
you see sometimes with different
services for different templates
depending on how they're served and the
level of traffic they have as well as
multiple content management systems as
well as ETL pipelines so we're not micro
service architecture but we service
architecture some a micro someone not so
micro but yeah most or not so my crowd
yes and here's our kind of architecture
diagram prior to migration I couldn't
fit all 50 services here but this is
kind of abstraction that I'm gonna walk
you through we had had two CD ends
firstly and Akamai we had f5 load
balancer which basically load-balanced
where to push the user to either tour
dynamic templates which would go to
varnish as you can see there and
warnings are caching layer which we put
in front of templates at the same time
templates talked to API to get the data
so API is in heart our system if not
then the f5 load bouncer would push the
user or the data requests to Apaches
which would serve all the static content
static HTML if we have that all the Java
scripts all the CSS files to would go
through that we also had a different
bridge here for specifically for our dam
digital asset management system which
included tambour open source software
which resized and compressed our images
that then went to Akamai which cached
and again another varnish layer and our
dem API for ETL we use
activemq and mules soft which was would
process all our messages all our data
and insert it in on Prem my sequel and
[ __ ] DB s we also had some things in
AWS our AI skills we moved to AWS as a
first step kind of a long time ago and
they're a crucial tour a CMS so we had
that there and in a nutshell this is
kind of our architecture prior to
migration yeah and then looking at this
as well as we deem said this is highly
abbreviated abstracted so there we
actually have templates
API as if those are like insignificant
kind of parts but there's multiple
template engines multiple api's that are
powering all this and that's where a
core of our application logic lives
within the larger abstracted
architecture yeah so moving to the cloud
there were challenges if any of you have
done it or attempted to I'm sure you're
aware of that as well so in one set of
those in particular was organizational
challenges we were in a very fortunate
situation at Forbes where we were
actually able to make the decision that
already had c-suite buy-in to invest in
moving from on-prem into the cloud and
we're also trusted within our own
organization to make decisions such as
let's move to GCP and that's the best
solution for us but we still need to get
team buy-in and when I say team buy-in I
also mean like fellow engineers DevOps
professionals networking and security
teams and making sure that we're
actually all aligned with moving forward
for that vision and we all believe that
it was the right set of tools and
technologies for us to work with another
big thing for us too was also picking a
consulting partner
we had it migrated certainly nothing of
this scale to the cloud before and
expertise and GCP was something we were
still developing very much so in-house
so we wanted someone who had experience
doing that multiple times to guide us
along the way and that our decisions as
we went along and finally of course
picking technology partners for that GCP
is one of them as is Google but I also
mean solutions such as how are we going
to handle monitoring how are we going to
handle passwords secret storage and
other additional choices along the way
yeah and what is managed for us what
would we have to kind of build their own
so a lot of decisions obviously prior to
to move on to the cloud and a lot of
challenges as we'll show you more in in
these slides so I want to touch base on
the migration timeline and how did we
approach each step so first step
decide on a cloud provider obviously was
critical for us we tried and did
prototypes with both three of the big
players obviously assure AWS and Google
we did kind of small applications that
we migrated we showed them to our
engineers DevOps and based on the
feedback and just the ease with which
they migrated those applications and how
did they like working with the platform
and just overall kind of cost obviously
was part of it
and a lot of different components there
we at the end decided to go with Google
and so far very happy with the decision
next up was speaking the actual partner
that will help us migrate and again same
approach with it too weak proof of
concepts with each of the partners we
had three even that we picked and the
one that we felt comfortable was the
team felt comfortable was the one that
provided us the best kind of plan
forward the best timeline for our
migration we picked that one and we
started to move forward next step for us
was critical and absolutely if you
planning to migrate I think this is
something you have to do it's kind of
discovering again your systems going
through inventory of each server that
you have each network that you have set
up
how do applications talk to each other
where do you have load balance and setup
where is the caching and where the
security setup lay what it can talk to
each other what can't this was so
critical for us that without this I
don't think we would have been
successful in not only that - Forbes is
a hundred-year-old company as well and
we've had a web presence since there was
well like a web so particularly for
companies with a history of that nature
- I think you're gonna find a lot of
skeletons in your closet along the way
our systems you didn't even know we're
running that are gonna have to be
accounted for yeah we definitely found
like Isis or were somewhere in the
closet along the way so yeah and so
doing that step it helps us a lot in
onboarding the partner right now we had
new kind of diagrams updated diagrams
and architecture kind of plans of how
everything works so we could actually
walk our partners through it and show
them how everything is set up so our
kind of onboarding of the our partner
was made a lot easier by us doing that
prep work prior so next step was
planning the architecture and figuring
out how it's gonna look in the cloud so
we have our architecture in
on pram and then how do we move it to
the cloud and that went through a lot of
different iterations to be honest and
until we were happy with it so that was
a step that was also critical for us
then the kickoff which was very exciting
we wanted to move forward as soon as
possible and we started migrate and at
some point obviously we realized that we
should do things different so that took
some time for us to get comfortable but
you are very happy to get everything
first to stay - development project and
then move everything to staging and then
start moving to production our approach
was to move to production in phases and
it was a good approach and mostly we
were doing it that way but under a
couple of gotchas we realized that our
core applications had to be moved
together and the reason for that is that
when you have your core applications
some of them in the cloud and some in a
data center we quickly realized there is
latency in that communication so we had
to make sure that our database our api's
and templates that talk to it had to be
moved at once and then everything else
we could kind of stagger alone and
migrate as we went through we also
obviously tested it very well on stage
in low tested that's very important
try to simulate production traffic it's
not easy but do as much as you can
obviously when you move to production
they're going to be some guy choose a
lecture share one we have a lot of
traffic to our site and what happened to
us is that there is a limit sent on cube
dns to 150 concurrent connections and we
realized that after we started migrating
so hope thankfully we were able to
change that but that was definitely
something that we did not expect and
yeah moving to staging move into
production we had to make sure that we
had a plan and had something real that
emitted setup where we can go from def
to stage into production with a click of
a button
next one of the first architectural
decision that we had was how do
about projects and we had couple of
schools of thought there one was we have
50 projects 50 applications why don't we
set up 50 different projects we quickly
realized that was difficult for us and
from security standpoint was not
manageable because now the same
developers the same person will have
access to both production development
and staging application which obviously
is not acceptable the second school of
thought was well then why don't we just
create one big project and have all the
applications there again mix the
management extremely easy but concerns
against security concerns again that
developer will have access to everything
so we could not allow that so the way
that we structured our projects was
something in the middle three projects
one for development and staging one for
production a one for our management
tools so something like JIRA confluence
Walt we would keep in our management
project separately for security reasons
and overall for easier management yeah
so that that's how we decided to
approach our project architecture yeah
so let's talk a little bit about how we
actually broke up the clusters inside of
those which that diagram already began
to allude to a little bit so in terms of
choosing what really lived beside other
applications on like a cluster level now
that we already had projects defined we
broke it up into kind of six main
categories forbes.com which was our
varnish caching layer all of our
templates applications and our API is
Vadim said having those live alongside
of each other was absolutely necessary
especially once we started to realize
the latency that was introduced between
communicating with TCP back to our data
center compared to how fast that could
be if everything was just side by side
the other one is our ETL pipelines and
tools related to that we named it mules
but it's activemq and mule soft living
alongside each other we have multiple
content management systems some used
more than others and all of those ended
up living inside of another one really
providing access to the right layer
for our editors and writers and that's
our authentication and permissions
application and API logging which
handles revision control as long as well
as access to content monitoring our AI
skills which augment our writing
facilities for writers as they go
through creating content and social BOTS
as well for posting to Twitter Linkedin
etc we also had dam which handled thumb
bore for images varnish for caching in
our dam API also with the upside on
smiley face is a legacy one which I will
not delve into everything that is in
there spoilers are that it is a much
longer list than the other ones and then
finally admin or management which badeen
talked about as well where we stored
Jenkins vault monitoring tools JIRA
confluence and any other kind of
utilities that allow us to deliver work
or work towards delivering work in the
day-to-day well in the reason the legacy
is separate is that at some point we
hope it's gonna go away and then this
cluster just doesn't exist right so we
looking forward to that day in the
future yeah it all slowly be migrated
out of existence yeah and one thing that
we had to really focus on and was new to
us in the cloud
was security in the data center we were
very comfortable with our security we
knew exactly how to handle it
everything was firewall nicely so we had
nothing to worry about at that point
because we had so much experience with
it starting to move to the cloud we
quickly realized that it's not going to
be that simple the reason is we move an
application HTTP access HTTP access is
immediately available to the world right
so we immediately started to pared
access down we had to make sure that
only applications that needed to talk to
each other
had that access so our diagram we did in
in a beginning our audit helped us a lot
we realized which applications had to
talk to each other and we would
carefully only allowed that level of
access we also obviously had to audit
all the roles and who has access to our
dev project management project to
production project we went left that
really small number of people to be able
to X
to production and management projects
because most of our deployments and
everything happens through the code so
in reality unless you really have to you
don't need to have access to those
projects by themselves and I want to
give a shout out or security and
networking team they've done an amazing
job they learned all of this and all
these new tools really quickly we could
not have done it without them they just
jumped on it they loved it and they set
it up really really well so really happy
the same and that's an amazing advantage
that we really had during all this - I
realize not every company actually has
internal networking teams in internal
security teams to provide assistance
with that and to do auditing throughout
so having them spin up their skills in
GCP and apply their pre-existing
knowledge really just put us in a much
more confident place throughout the
whole process and learning new
technologies like he still which we
obviously didn't have was critical for
us like kind of how easy it makes kind
of our networking and splitting traffic
and things like that was really amazing
for us so let's talk a little bit about
the refactor itself and what changed as
we went from our data center into GCP so
what we originally thought and this
makes a tremendous amount of sense to me
hopefully it does to all of you as well
is we're gonna evaluate if Google as a
managed solution right they have
something like cloud dataflow data proc
like whatever we're just gonna use
that'll be fantastic we don't need to do
anything right if they don't have one
for it though that's fine too we can
move it as it is we'll just throw it in
a compute instance and we'll refactor it
later the important thing for us let's
just get out of the data center so after
that though oh yeah it seems highly
illogical I led with that my bad yeah so
but if we were going to containerize we
had already containerized something why
don't we orchestrate it right and once
we have it orchestrated well now it
makes sense for us to include a network
mesh like sto into the process - and now
that we have all three of those layers
as well and we have 50 services what are
we going to do but we need to automate a
way to not only like deploy those but to
move those from you know dev staging
prod do migrations do network updating
snoop patching and then of course like
we can't write an individual pipeline
for all 50 services
we need to abstract it into something
that can actually run across all of
those
so while originally we were like oh
we're just gonna move them into the
cloud and be done with it
very soon after we got through step one
we found ourselves going layer and layer
of abstraction higher as we moved along
with migration and I think one of the
biggest things that kind of came out of
that was a highly configurable master
Jenkins build that does a lot of what I
talked about before it's highly
parameterised which actually means it
requires a bit of training just to know
how to build to it you can hit last
build too if you know the service but
this isn't just building something out
like a new feature into production non
production into dev environments which
is automated or moving that over to
staging this is really for like setting
up our infrastructure and connections
between new services as we move them
between those different layers or
introduce a completely new application
into our architecture overall so if you
needed to set up a new cluster set up
node pools set up networking set up new
DNS entries everything can be done with
couple of settings and click of a button
so this file actually so crucial for us
that moving from death to stage from
stage to production or introduce a new
application on new cluster or even
upgrade in the cluster ID which happens
a lot was breeds for us very very
important to automate in my opinion
yeah which landed us with our new stack
so of course we've already talked about
kubernetes quite a bit we also have
Google Cloud storage sto bigquery helm
we have cloud functions currently just
for billing alerts but that's also very
important so please set those up if
you're moving over as well as activemq
you'll soft
hashey core vault for password and
secret storage MongoDB Atlas is our
database for all environments but we're
now in Atlas as well as Alaska file
which replaces our pre-existing head end
and here's our new architecture diagram
in cloud it's very nicely structured and
clear and clean in my opinion so we have
one CDN fastly in front of it no five
load bouncing anymore the clusters are
divided as we discussed before our core
cluster has one edge template
an API really close to each other so
there is no latency we have the damn
digital asset management cluster which
has tumblr for asides and Warner's
vocation and MAPI a homegrown solution
we also have a CMS which is a single app
application living and cloud storage
those AI skills that we had in AWS we
migrated pretty easily to GCP so they
have kind of their own place there then
ETL cluster is also separated again our
active on queues and our mule soft
MongoDB in Atlas huge help everything
can be done on a fly there upgrades
indexes whatever you need so we don't
have to worry about that so hosted
MongoDB solution and if you recall we
were MongoDB before the migration is
yell but we moved over to Atlas versus
hosting that ourselves as we were moving
into the cloud yeah and they offer all
three providers cloud providers
obviously we use in Google and one thing
that we had to do for speed
we had to peer our applications you know
Google cloud kind of project to the
actual atlas project and Atlas mongos so
that was very critical for us because we
did see latency it first and then we
after we did that and the speed was
improved tremendously
we Apache servers that we had in front
of NFS also in kubernetes now and and
the first we did a lot of proof of
concepts and we moved to elasti file
kind of a hosted solution for that so
yeah abstracted a little bit but that's
in a nutshell our new architecture one
of the most powerful things from this as
well as looking back to our old
architecture there was a lot of bespoke
solutions right it was like how things
had evolved over time and patched and
part of moving over to the cloud and
that Jenkins build we talked about
before was really taking a moment to see
how we could reconfigure things and
abstract them in another level which
also makes her to be frank a much
prettier architecture diagram to present
at conferences - yeah and obviously
kubernetes everywhere pretty much and
easier for networking so the learnings
what did we learn from our
aggression one thing real we quickly
realized we have to monitor our costs
set up alerts there make sure that you
really estimate well of what things
going to cost you and make sure you have
really rigorous alerts set up so you get
notified if something happens we learn
really quickly in the beginning that we
accidentally turned on debug log in on
our sto to go to stackdriver
and now course spiked right we luckily
managed to catch it pretty quickly if it
didn't I don't know how much it would
have cost us but after that we set up
alerts really nicely and now anything
happens we get a notification in slack
and by email that something is going up
I'm watching those numbers tick up and
semi real time for the alerts was it's
quite an experience as well until we
turn that off it's exciting it's very
different from being in a data center
where everything is kind of static
another struggle and challenge was
taking a lot of new tack at once so
obviously we had to learn a lot of new
technologies and we didn't want to leave
a lot of technical debt so kind of
managing that of taking on a lot of new
stuff like East your hound that we had
no experience before and also doing
things right was definitely something we
had to manage team skills growth versus
a timeline our timeline was pretty
aggressive and again kind of making sure
that the team was comfortable with new
tag was comfortable supporting cloud and
our first structure in the cloud versus
also pushing forward quickly another
challenge that that we had and doing a
lot of different pocs so one thing that
we learn and I think is a great thing to
do is fail quickly when you do proof of
concepts and don't get attached if
something doesn't work just move on and
do another proof of concept find the
right solution for you a layer of
abstraction that is that - was we
actually introduced helm earlier on in
our process but not at the very
beginning and it came onto our radar
shortly after we started an already
gotten some work done and the same kind
of applies to the inverse of proof of
concepts is if you've already started
down one road in the
discover something you're like actually
this is just gonna abstract it on a
completely different level so we don't
have to worry about it looking at the
gains of making that switch versus
doubling down on the road that you've
already taken can actually save a
tremendous amount of time and effort in
the long run - yeah and the last point
is balancing movement quickly manually
and building automation was really
critical for us so obviously the urges
to move quickly and what we started to
do is start it just move things over
with kubernetes but a lot of the things
were set up manually like cluster setup
manual upgrades were manual a lot of
builds were Virginians but kind of
setting up security set up networking
DNS was done manually and we would
realize every time as like when we do
something
why don't we automate it so we would
take a step forward take a couple of
steps back and we would do that a lot
actually at least a few times for each
but I think it's worth it I think if one
thing that I had to change I would try
to build that foundation and build
automation from the get-go it's hard to
know that in the beginning before you
actually come into something because
every time you do something like ah okay
we doing it manually why don't we go
back automate it and at the end where we
came to is we can do have all of that
with some configuration and a click of a
button and you might feel like you're
losing time by taking those back steps
but especially when we got in the crunch
towards the end of our timeline and it
just became choosing a couple options
from drop-down menus and jenkins versus
having to do like actual work to move
things along it paid dividends
definitely will help you we learned that
pretty quickly and now the benefits
right obviously speed to market what it
helps us with with our kind of process
of deployment of process of approvals
with our stakeholders and product owners
now we can easily when we have a feature
create a box which we can send out all
our stakeholders or anybody in the
company to take a look
approve it and then we can push it to
production obviously it reduces manual
work now our apps and devops team
doesn't need to do many patches they
don't have to
go to the data center and I don't know
servers not none of that is needed to be
handled by us now and that's all handled
by Google in which we are very happy
about see ICD pipelines obviously much
easier again generated those boxes and
environments on the fly for each
application for each feature so they can
be reviewed by stakeholders or QA
critical Canary deployments so basically
pushing some percentage of the traffic
to up to new release and then if it goes
well push it to 100% if not just
scaled-down destroyed the Box that is
really big for us for our kind of
stability and scalability and a be
testing a be testing is something that
is crucial to our company we base most
of our major decisions or pretty much
all our decisions on KPIs so what we
need to do we need to a B test every
main feature that we release and being
in the cloud makes it much easier we can
spin up a new environment point some
traffic to it then collect the data and
see how it performs and then scalability
right if we need to process a lot of
data for example at once we can just
scale up and that's it before that what
we had to do is basically over-provision
our servers and have huge machines in a
data center that basically were ideal
90% of the time and only were needed
maybe like I don't know a couple of days
a year so it was a waste basically or
just to prepare for some huge traffic
spikes now it's all scaleable and
automated and yeah we just basically
what we used to do is have huge boxes
sittin there for no reason on the note
of scalability - part of that for us in
our particular industry is also
unpredictability right
if Forbes we really share the stories of
people's success and some of those
people are very successful so when they
tweet about an article or something
that's going on on Forbes that can
generate a pretty tremendous spike in
traffic going to particular pages or
services another thing is we started to
move faster and faster through all of
this as well
was also being able to scale Jenkins
right and getting that into K eights and
really what it was is once we started to
have a proper pipeline with boxes built
on every on every pull request for
product owner approval we hit
bottlenecks very quickly when we were
still in the data center but moving that
over and having that be abstracted a
layer away just removed all those
worries
yeah but definitely one thing make sure
that all those boxes they're not laying
around that you actually destroy them so
obviously set up some automation that
bugs gets basically killed every time
you don't need it anymore
the way for us it works is basically
when developer creates a pull request
the dev box gets created and when it's
merged it basically gets destroyed so
that way we manage it and don't just
create an infinite number of yeah
institutions right yeah so soon to be
integrated or what we're really looking
towards for the future now that we're
already in GCP and and cutover looking
to expand that even more so like I said
we're using cloud functions but right
now we're using them for billing alerts
there's definitely more potential there
there's definitely some things to be
solved along the way in terms of code
management deployments and how we
actually handle that with our team and
it's scale but increasingly so more and
more cloud auto ml machine learning and
AI is major to Forbes as it is to a
tremendous amount of companies right now
for us it particularly ties into
editorial assistance and how we work
with work with our writers though it
definitely bleeds into a number of other
parts of our organization as well it's
the skills that we showed you basically
and a lot of them are based on using
some of these Google technologies that
are amazing and we're really happy to
have those API is available to us so we
don't have to actually write our own NLP
or sentiment analysis and things like
that so we use them that a lot but as
new ones get kind of created all the
time we would like to expand as much as
possible for sure and adding that layer
of abstraction helps our team move with
increased velocity as well
so cloud dataflow actually a similar
vein for our ETL pipelines and looking
to see how that might be able to
abstract some of the more manual work
that we do right now
manual being manual coding not human
doing work cloud pub/sub dissimilar but
abstracted effect and I think the real
next step for us is now that we have
this whole architecture migrated over to
Google cloud is setting it up with
terraform so that not only can we set up
and build new applications new instances
and migrate those between dev staging
and production but so we can set up an
entirely new ecosystem on the fly as we
need to and we already started on that
and right now yes we kind of discussed
to mention we can create application
cluster anything in that environment but
we want to be able to with one push of a
button to generate everything right away
or anywhere right so this is gonna be a
huge step for us in the future and I
think that's pretty much the next step
for us which is well underway
[Music]